今日我哋會講下聖經末世的預兆
每日一字先 呢度有兩個字
邊個係個末字呢?
我覺得中國人係好有智慧的
你發覺個末字上面係長啲 下面係短啲
你發覺係咪好似越走越窄 到到一個盡頭咁樣
相反個未字就係上面窄啲 下面闊啲
越走越闊闊然開朗有一個新的境界
這兩個字都可以代表著我們今天的聚會的盼望
盼望你的人生從末日轉為未來
從窮途末路
進到這個燦爛的未來
不知道大家有沒有留意一些新聞
有時有些新聞裏面有些很嚇人的景象
有時會用末日去形容的
譬如這幅照片你看見是幾年前
2017年 報道說關火
燒得很厲害 沖天的煙場
又例如半年前
在印尼婆羅洲森林大火
燒得很厲害
其實是日頭來的
但是整天都紅了
有些形容到紅得好像世界末日
又好像近來的疫情
在南韓大休市
因为有爆发,整个市都没什么人
死亡直到末日一样
有时一些报道有意无意间都提到圣经的
这个就是一个星期前的一个新闻
讲到有个警告就是前面世界会有饥荒
那他怎么形容呢?
他说圣经级的大饥荒
即是一个Feminine of Biblical Proportions
甚至一隻牛仔出世
這裡都講到會惹起末日的憂慮
這些新聞一會兒我們有機會可以重溫一下
在疫情裏面我曾經見過這幅照片
我覺得幫這些石頭戴口罩的人都是有心
不過我就想起那8個字
就是真神造人、假神人造
如果这些石头流感染病毒都还好
但是假神是人造的
真神是造人的
他既然造人
人有理智
有分析能力
而这位神他当然也有
给很多证据我们
让我们在理智上知道他的真实
他的存在
他的宝贵
其中一个证据就是圣经
圣经里面充满了预言
有人统计过
圣经有超过四分一的篇幅是预言
顾名思义预言的意思是一件事未发生
预先讲了出来
到时候到的时候
真的这样发生
其实透过预言
使我们知道神是真实
圣经里面讲的那位是真神
也同时
想我们有预备的
特登预备
满天黑云
如果你出街
那你是不是带把伞
所以同样透过预言神都想我们有所预备的
到底圣经里面有没有说到关乎到末日末世的事呢?
二千年前当主耶稣在地上的时候
有一次他和门徒一起
门徒就问了主耶稣一个这样的问题
他说什么呢?
他说你告诉我们知道你降临和世界的末了有什么预兆
圣经真的告诉我们有世界末了
不过我想强调
这个世界末了就不是说The end of the world
所有人死了
如果你看英文就更加清楚了
这里说什么呢
The end of the age
一个时代的完结
圣经说到世界末了是说一个时代、一个阶段的完结
这个完结牵涉到什么呢
就是主耶稣的降临
原来主耶稣会再一次回来
祂要开始一个新的时代
主接着就回答门徒
祂就说什么呢
就着他们问关于末世有什么预兆呢
主就说了
祂说你们要谨慎
因为将来有些人冒我的名
甚至说我是基督
并且要迷惑许多人
你们也听见打仗和打仗的风声
民要攻打民
国要攻打国
多處有饑荒、地震
這些都是災難的起頭
但我想你留意一下
災難是原文作生產之難
意思是什麼呢?等於一個女人生孩子
你發覺當她走快臨盤的時候
這些的陣痛會越來越頻密
越來越厲害
這個就是生產之難的意思
就是說你看到的不單只有這些跡象
並且這些跡象會越來越頻密
越來越厲害
剛才我們是不是留意那則新聞
南韓的大休市死值好像沒人了
其實為什麼呢
因為當日在大休有這個厲害的爆發
而這個爆發主要是牽涉到一些大型的聚會
我想你在報導裏面聽過了
就是所謂新天地教會
不知道你知不知道
這個創辦人他自稱自己是耶穌基督來的
原來在南韓自稱自己是耶穌基督的人有20多個
又真的有很多人聽他們講
其實2020年這幾個月世界局勢很緊張
你想想波斯灣的戰爭
美國和伊朗的緊張氣氛
延續到今天4月都仍然戰雲密布
所以有些人可能他新年的願望就是世界和平
聖經講到除了打仗之外
也都特別提到有擾亂的事
擾亂的事,Commotion是什麼意思呢?
就是說不單止好像剛才講的國要攻打國
就是民要攻打民
擾亂的事就是一些disturbance
一些騷亂、擾亂
譬如歷時年紀的法國的王培森示威
又或者上年香港的反修例抗爭
你發覺在世界各地都有這些騷亂
而這些是會越來越嚴重越來越厲害的
我不知道這個牛家庭呢
有沒有想過這一天
吃吃草地突然間周圍的地凹了下去
其實這幅照就是有一次紐西蘭地震
周圍的草地就凹了下去
成為一個孵島
這幅圖片我們看到近100年
地震的情況
5級以上的地震不是一個小的地震
是大的地震
而你看到地震的頻率發生的情況
是越來越多越來越頻密的
所以還記得生產之難
因此,這次的疫情稱為Pandemic,
即是全球大流行。
你知道Pandemic這個字其實希腊文的意思,
即是All People,
即是牽涉到所有人。
你想想,短短兩個月間,
已經全世界每一個國內,
即是全球都有確診的個案。
所以聖經說,
多處都有饑荒瘟疫
你睇見
真係多處
聖經裏面講到瘟疫呢仲有一個特點
除了多處之外
亦都講到
死的人殺的人是好多
譬如這節聖經提到
透過刀劍、饑荒瘟疫殺的人
甚至有成四分一
人口
有沒有想過四分一是什麼意思
全球77億人
四分一即死了19億人
即是說中國13億加上美國3億多
都不夠填這條數
其實這幅照片裏面你都可以看見今次的疫情
你看見很多名字
其實這些傳染病全部是2000年之後即是說這20年裏面發生的
無論霍亂、豬流感、腦膜炎、沙士、麻疹、伊波拉
冬冬沙士
这个就打破了一个迷思
有些人觉得21世纪医学昌明
不会有这样的瘟疫的
但是你看短短20年
发生的瘟疫传染病是很多
而今次这个肺炎
你想想去到3月19号的时候
死了9000人
一个月之后
这个就是4月20号
已经由9000人跳到17万人了
都相当吓人的
下面的表可以看到我昨天检查过
直到4月30号全球感染的人超过300万
死亡人数有23万多
这个数目当然不小
但如果比较全世界的人口77亿人
其实染病的人只不过是0.04%
什么意思呢
1万人只得4人染病
死的人10萬個只有3個
有人這樣說
如果疫情要舒緩
要有群體免疫
可能病毒要傳到6、7成的人
才有機會緩和
由0.04%去到6、70%
其實還有很漫長的路
剛才有提到
前面世界可能會有饑荒
為什麼用聖經級的饑荒去形容呢?
就是講到這個饑荒是很嚴重
還有很多地方會發生
其實我看過一些是
現在是很嚴重的
什麼呢?
就是很多地方的農莊、很多農產品
因為疫症的問題
沒有工人去收割
有些人收割了就沒有人來收
就算收了之後
也都沒有運輸的
因為沒有飛機
沒有運輸
結果很多農產品就要棄置
比如美國將很多牛奶都倒進去
比如大陸是不是將很多雞仔都賣光了
比如歐洲將很多農產品要將它利封
你可以看見在可見的裏面
其實前面可能兩三月裏面
全球會有饑荒發生
再加上就是你可能聽過近這幾個月
就是反复到沙漠蝗蟲
今次的蝗蟲是70年裏面最嚴重的
影響到譬如非洲的情況
索馬里、肯亞、埃塞俄比亞
影響到阿拉伯半島
甚至蝗蟲飛到巴基斯坦、阿富汗
有人會擔心
到底蝗蟲會不會飛到中國
入侵中國呢
入侵中國就大件事了
這麼多人口
你也有人這樣說
唔怕唔怕唔怕
因為蝗蟲在中國的蝗蟲呢
是不敢四隻飛埋一齊呀
就不是因為有限聚令
而是因為佢哋八片做串燒啫
咁最近還有一個新聞呢
就是在湄公河的下游五個國家啦
比如說越南啊、柬埔寨啊
泰國啊、緬甸這些
這些都是傳統的糧倉來的喎
但由於湄公河呢
水量減少啊
你看那些照片呢
那個河床都露了出來
令到下游這些國家就有這個旱災
但是這一次呢
其實就不是天然的
主要就是因為中國在雲南地方就建了水壩
用來水力發電
這樣就窄了那些水
其實這個都使我們想到一個問題的
其實現在大部分的河流呢
它的水源就來自高山
譬如這個青藏高原這樣
而因為全球暖化呢
令到很多高山上面的冰川溶解
你可以想像一下
水塔没有水
下游的河流哪里有水呢
如果没有水
其实农作物就没得灌溉了
所以这是一个很大潜在
关乎粮食的危机
不知道大家最近有没有留意这个新闻
科学家就很紧张
因为在北半球在北极上空
出現了一個很大的臭氧洞
臭氧Ozone其實是用來綁著太陽的紫外光
如果紫外光照射到地面
如果人身上可能會長皮膚癌、白內障
紫外光也同樣會破壞農作物
所以這個都會影響到糧食的供應
不過很寶貴
这个臭氧洞一个月里面很快就恢复了
其实最主要的原因是因为天气回暖了
想到这里我都觉得神祂真是有怜悯
天气回暖了就令到这个臭氧洞很快复合
同时因为天气回暖
北半球的疫情也有一些缓和的迹象
大家刚才还记得这两幅照吗
原来圣经里面讲到主后面当主回来之前的前夕
地要大震动,日头要变黑好像毛布
满月变红好像血
我相信不是太阳或者月亮有什么问题
我相信是大气层出了问题
这节圣经里面之后也有这么提
它就讲到不单止日头月亮
它還說天上的星辰都墜落於地
好像無花果樹被大風搖動
落下未熟的果子一樣
可能你會想
什麼星辰墜落?
說的我相信不是金星、火星
如果那些撞下來就沒有了
在18年的時候
中國的太空站
天宮一號就走到最後一程了
墜落這個地球
在大氣層磨擦燃燒
加上解體
你見到那幅照片就是這樣的情況
知不知眾星墜落
在上個禮拜
不知道有沒有留意這個新聞
其實有一個叫做星鏈計劃
它的計劃裏面
想著升空有1萬2千個衛星
用來覆蓋全球
令到所有人能夠手機
直接沿路衛星上網
現在已經在年紀裏面已經射了400多個衛星
因為你知道如果它們太高就很難接觸到
所以它們都比較低的
距離地面大約300公里左右
200多里左右
如果一旦這些衛星出了問題
其實衛星最大的問題不是它的大小
而是它的速度
這些衛星45分鐘已經環繞地球一周
如果一旦這些衛星有什麼差池
其實同一個高度的所有的這些衛星就會橫掃
就會產生一個連鎖的反應
不知道大家有沒有看過Gravity引力邊緣那支電影
它講的就是這個問題
我想如果到時這樣的時候橫掃
我想全天都是滿天都是星辰墜落
又例如呢度呢提过呢只牛仔出世啦
为什么这么轰动呢
除了说2000年来都没有一只红色的牛出世之外呢
其实最主要呢就是关乎到呢以色列人
他们梦寐以求呢就想重建圣殿呀
恢复献祭
但如果他们要重建圣殿
一定要建在哪里呢建在耶路撒冷
就算给他建好
它都要洁净聖殿、洁净祭司才能去獻祭
而那隻红母牛其實就是用來洁净的
它們將那隻牛大約兩三歲左右燒成灰
用紅母牛的灰洁净聖殿的器具、洁净祭司、恢復獻祭
所以2000年來它們都找不到紅母牛
當紅母牛出現的時候
他們在很多猶太人心目中覺得重建聖殿的時候到了
如果你看一下新聞
其實美國在這些日子裏面對以色列的策略不同了
將領事館搬去紐西蘭
其實他一心想締造中東的和平
所以有沒有聽過世紀頁二促成以色列和巴勒斯坦的和议
將來這個和议一定會達成的
不過未必是美國主導
當它達成的時候 它能夠重建聖殿
恢復献祭 我都很想看到
它們獻牛犊燒成灰的時候 為什麼呢?
因為從它們選在哪裡獻
也可以讓我們知道
它心目中的聖殿的位置在哪裡
我們就基本拭目以待
咁我哋知道呢兩點呢能夠連成一條直線
如果好多點
都落到一條直線裏面嘅時候呢
我哋會睇見呢
其實呢個方向係確定嘅
當你睇見頭先咁多嘅跡象
假基督啦
打仗啦
蘇聯啦
地震、饑荒、瘟疫啦
日月星嘅變異啦
關乎到以色列人
聖殿嘅重建等等啦
你發覺朝中嘅方向嘅
係咩呢
就是主耶穌要回來
主耶穌也都快回來
願我們預備迎見主